Join me explore the multiverse
and ask the question what if
everybody knows how iron man became iron man
how cap became cat the fun twist is that we
go in different directions and what does that
look like and it's like wait what what if as
a concept and as a comic book is something
that would always come up in conversation
it was almost like it was marvel's twilight zone
for our show we're not borrowing anything that
was pre-done in the comic we're riffing on the
marvel movie cinematic version of those characters
that's what's wonderful about this what
if concept anything can be explored
what if ultron won what if thor was
never banished what happens next
when brian and brad pitched the
notion of using norman rockwell
as a basis for the style of the show i mean that's
that's my bread and butter i love that stuff
it's pretty exciting when you see it all come
together that's some of the best storytelling
we've ever had what if gives us a whole new idea
of what the physical reality of the universe is
that is something that's going to be explored
in other ways moving forward in our films
i really believe that deepening fictional
mythologies is a way to appreciate them more
as a way to to understand them more look at them
in a different way and they've got now two seasons
of what if uh ideas underway that that some of the
best storytelling we've ever had and you may see
spin into other into other mediums but is really
the most uniquely beautiful animated series i've
seen a long time obviously you can spin out any
number of what-if stories and it's exciting to do
so but you're searching for that central thread
that could make it feel like essential viewing
for the mcu and what emerged was the relationship
between captain carter and the watcher which
is something that that evolves uh in a in a
grand fashion in the second season of the show
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
will be my what if season 2 teaser video
marvel's been releasing a couple promos
the creators have been talking about what's
happening with the season 2 episodes there's a
bunch of easter eggs so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel i'm also doing
a giveaway for disney plus memberships and movie
tickets all you have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber and let me know which stories you want
them to do during what if season two everybody
always has some great suggestions but if you guys
didn't know they actually have all their episodes
pretty much blocked out the scripts are mostly
done and storyboarded out like they're going to be
animating episodes really soon for about the next
year or so and try to get episodes out late next
year or if they delay it early in 2023 but right
now the plan is for them to do 10 episodes like
they were originally going to do during season one
there were just some delays because of the virus
that's why there were only nine episodes the
tenth episode was the missing iron man episode
of him being stuck on sakhar it was basically
them giving the plot of thor ragnarok to iron man
and combining it with the first half of avengers
infinity war with thanos going around collecting
all the infinity stones that's why when they were
forming the guardians of the multiverse during
the finale you saw that quick sequence with
gamora to explain how she got thanos armor and his
weapon and then wound up on the guardians of the
multiverse the reason why iron man is in that junk
looking version of an iron man hulkbuster suit is
because somehow he wound up getting sent to sakaar
instead of the hulk and while he was there just
like thor had to fight the contest of champions
against the hulk iron man had to fight against
gamora but because he's iron man he built himself
an iron man suit dumpster diving because it's
basically a trash planet so he built himself a
hulk buster out of trash call it the trash buster
but the idea was that after they fight a little
bit they come together they team up and then wind
up creating the infinity crusher device to destroy
that universe's version of the infinity stones and
they came to the dwarven home world here where
thor came to get stormbreaker to help build that
infinity crusher device so during what if episode
nine we were just kind of seeing the very end of
that episode but i'm assuming the first episode of
season 2 will be a follow-up with captain carter
and her version of the winter soldier which is now
kind of like the hydra stomper winter soldier with
the skinny boy steve rogers in there there were a
couple moments at the end of episode one that sort
of imply what happened to him and how he wound
up in this situation becoming a version of winter
soldier he yells at bucky to put him back in
the hydra stomper so in the same way that winter
soldier basically got cryo frozen then unfrozen
to go out on missions even though he had the
super soldier serum in him which slowed his aging
process even more the same kind of thing happened
to skinny boy steve rogers with him thawing him
out every once in a while to go on missions then
putting him back on ice and that's how he survived
to present day but the whole idea is who was using
him on these missions was it a version of hydra
was it some other organization and we'll just
get into that during the next captain carter
episode they also talked during this about how
the watchers relationship is going to evolve
with captain carter and the other characters
as well that like new version of guardians of the
multiverse that they put together i don't think
that everybody's going to come back the roster
will have to cycle a little bit because killmonger
is now battling it out for the infinity stones in
that pocket dimension and chadwick boseman passed
away after he recorded all of his episodes so
they can't really do a version of black panther
unless they give the mantle to someone else during
the series they kind of did that with killmonger
but i'm not expecting them to go back to that well
so soon like here's another version of killmonger
that also became black panther the other really
cool thing if you're looking for clues on episodes
if you look in the background of this promo here
you look at their whiteboard there's actually 11
episodes that they have up there like what is
this mystery 11th episode we thought there were
10 they wheeled it down to 9. so like they're two
missing episodes but i'm assuming some of these
ideas that are on the white board just got pushed
to season two it says maria and the cree save
carol danvers which is probably meant to be what
if maria rambeau was saved by the cree instead of
carol danvers in service of doing a big reference
to the monica rambeau version of captain marvel
the original female captain marvel in the comics
maria rambeau is monica rambeau's mother and in
this version of events assuming maria rambeau who
was carol danvers fellow test pilot was just the
one to fly the test mission with the faster than
light tesseract engine that mar-vell was building
meaning that she's the one that got shot down
in the crash and then rescued by yawn rog in
the creek and would wind up getting a version of
a captain marvel origin story just flipping the
roles i did a lot of videos about monica rambeau
and her powers during the one division episodes
i'll post a link to that video down in the
description below because she is super op in the
comics they'll be addressing a lot of those easter
eggs for monica rambeau captain marvel spectrum
photon whichever name they're gonna go with from
the comics inside the mcu and develop her powers
more but even cooler underneath this designated as
episode 7 is titled 1988 avengers i think that's
just meant to be what if the avengers formed
during 1988 earlier in the timeline who would
have been on that team just for reference tony
stark would have been 18 at the time so he still
would have been finishing at mit he graduated mit
really young howard stark would still be in his
early 70s pretty old but still alive to work with
the team like an old man iron man 100 hank pym and
janet van dyne would have been on the team since
they would have been relatively middle-aged at the
time as the original ant-man and the wasp janet
van dyne was also one of the founding members
of the avengers in the comics as well too but for
instance thor would look exactly the same because
as guardians aged so slowly so there would have
been almost no difference in him being on the team
you can still find captain america in the ice just
a little bit earlier and thaw him out he'd still
look the exact same and the ancient one would have
been around and available for the team as well but
you notice how much they talk about daredevil what
if stories silver surfer infinity gauntlet stories
there's a lot of fantastic four in here too just
because the watcher comes from the fantastic four
comics so they spend a lot of this talking about
fantastic four characters there's a ghostwriter
what if story in there a shongxi what if story
even a galactus what if story they do clarify
that they're not doing any direct comic book
adaptations from the wooded comics like they're
not doing a copy paste version of any of the comic
book what if stories they're just riffing on some
of those ideas and using mcu characters to do it
kevin feige also talked a lot about doing marvel
zombies in the mcu they said season one was their
first foray but not the last one so we'll probably
see more marvel zombie stories in future seasons
and when kevin feige talks about seeing the
characters show up in other mediums he's talking
about these animated what-if characters from other
universes showing up in the live-action marvel
projects like live-action marvel disney plus
series and live-action marvel movies the character
that they've most talked about showing up in live
action first is hayley atwell's captain carter
they didn't say which movie they were planning
on putting her in first but just that she would
eventually show up in live action i know there
are a lot of people that are wondering if there's
a version of doctor strange supreme like a darker
doctor strange in spiderman no way home but
i don't think that's the case it's just that
any time any marvel character acts a little sus
people like maybe they're a squirrel maybe they're
mephisto maybe they're secretly someone else it's
still supposed to be the regular version of doctor
strange from this universe but talking more
about season two characters coming back doctor
strange supreme is still probably one of the most
important characters to come out of season one
the big difference with them going into season two
from season one is that they were actually writing
all the season one episodes before they knew about
what was happening during the marvel phase four
projects which is why you don't see like alligator
loki running around during what if season one the
advantage now is when they were writing all the
scripts they knew what was happening during marvel
phase 4 so they can incorporate new characters
from the newer marvel phase 4 movies and disney
plus series they talked about doing characters
from the shangshi movie eternals characters
obviously they know what happens to spiderman no
way home and they can do spiderman characters but
they'll also know about thor love and thunder
black panther 2 guardians of the galaxy 3 along
with elena bulova from the black widow movie who's
now the de facto main black widow of the mcu in
present day and like i said all the loki variants
alligator loki tva loki mobius renslayer kang he
who remains even what happened during one division
billy and tommy white vision john walker us agent
the new falcon version of captain america val
madam hydra the contessa all them will eventually
start showing up during what-if episodes either
season two season three they didn't say how many
seasons they're going to be doing but i'm
assuming they'll at least get season three
and because this teaser just features so much
ghost rider daredevil silver surfer fantastic
four stuff even galactus stuff part of what they
explain is the limit on their series is they can
only do characters that have already shown up in
the series and in the movies so far meaning that
most of the core x-men characters are probably off
limits fantastic four characters like we won't see
them until the new fantastic four movie comes out
and the first big x-bang characters core x-men
characters like wolverine and the others start
showing up in live-action deadpool would also be
an easy slam dunk too so eventually deadpool will
show up in the what if series just because he's
tailor-made for that kind of stuff so everyone
let me know in the comments which new characters
from marvel phase 4 do you want to see show up
during season 2 and what kind of stories do you
want them to do there's a couple other trailer
videos that i'm working on i'll post in the next
couple of days make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss that and i'll
just leave this round of the giveaway open for the
next couple of videos everyone click here for my
eternals doctor strange trailer video and easter
eggs and click here for my eternals movie review
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!